All right, one more time.
We're now looking at a framework to help us as we try to market our products,
this is the ACCORD framework.
Use it when you're designing your new product.
The ACCORD framework helps us to predict
which product or products will quote "cross the chasm,"
from the early adopters in the market to the early and late majority,
and then finally the late adopters.
It's an acronym that stands for advantage, compatibility,
complexity, observability, risk, and divisibility.
We need to maximize advantage, compatibility,
observability, and divisibility, and minimize complexity and risk.
ACCORD is useful anytime you design a product
because it gives you the levers that will help determine the product's adoption.
It can also help you understand why a product may have failed.
Although it doesn't give you precise guidelines of how much each factor matters,
it can give you an overall sense of how your product will
do or why your product succeeded or failed in the past.
When YouTube first launched,
there was another site called Metacafe in which people could post video content.
Essentially, Metacafe was YouTube before YouTube was YouTube.
So why did YouTube succeed and Metacafe eventually fail?
We can't know for a fact,
but the ACCORD framework helps us understand the likely reason.
In order to view video content on Metacafe,
a user had to either go to the site or download a video player.
In contrast, YouTube made things less complex and more compatible.
If you want to share a video,
you can simply share the embed code in an email the recipient would click and voila,
out would come the video.
So YouTube made it easier and less complicated to share the content than Metacafe,
the rest is history.
Google purchased YouTube for over $1.6 billion and nowadays,
YouTube is a major revenue generator for Google.
Another example is satellite radio.
When Sirius first launched,
satellite radio was a standalone device that had to be installed on a car dashboard.
The installation included drilling a hole in the car's roof to accommodate an antenna.
Initial sales were quite slow and the ACCORD framework helps us understand why.
The product suffered from two major problems.
The first one is incompatibility.
If I have to drill a hole in my car,
the device is hardly compatible.
The second problem relates to risk.
Buyers had to rely on an unproven service that depended on really expensive satellites.
I could spend a good amount of money installing a device that maybe I couldn't use.
So when did satellite radio really take off?
When Sirius radios began to be integrated to the existing car radio,
the company increased compatibility and reduced the perception of risk.
After all, if my car comes with a device already implanted,
it seems like a less risky proposition.